let's talk now a little bit about the
discussions of the countless at this
point who knows what the number is is it
ten eleven seventeen sexual assault
accusers of Donald Trump my
recommendation my thought yesterday
before the debate with Hillary Clinton
should really step back from the
specifics of the allegations when she is
given the opportunity to comment on it
and say I'm here to talk about issues
voters have heard the allegations voters
will judge the allegations let's talk
through a little bit of how that part of
the debate went we will start first with
an answer from Donald Trump which to me
makes absolutely no sense why would so
many different women from so many
different circumstances over so many
different years why would they all in
this last couple of weeks make up you've
denied us why would they all make up
these stories and since this is a
question for both of you Secretary
Clinton mr. Trump says what your husband
did and that you defended was even worse
mr. Trump you go first well first of all
those stories have been largely debunked
those people I don't know those people I
have a feeling how they came I believe
it was her campaign that did it just
like if you look at what came out today
on the clips where I was wondering what
happened with my rally in Chicago and
other rallies where we had such violence
she's the one in Obama that caused the
violence they hired people they paid
them $1,500 and they're on tape saying
be violent cause fights do bad things I
would say the only way because those
stories are all totally false I have to
say that and I didn't even apologize to
my wife who's sitting right here because
I didn't do anything
I don't know that Donald Trump said
anything in that answer that's true
except I do believe he didn't apologize
to his wife that actually rings true to
me number one saying that switching
gears and trying to accuse Hillary
Clinton of paying people to be violent
at his rallies that that's been
completely debunked in reality but then
claiming that all of these stories from
women have been debunked not a single
one of these accusers has been debunked
as Donald Trump claims one woman he
claimed he never met although five
months ago he said something very
different that that's former Miss Utah
this was an answer
made no sense now I'm gonna play
Hilary's answer it's not exactly what I
would have liked to see her do but it
was a strong answer and I believe she
handled this well let's take a listen he
went on to say look at her I don't think
so about another woman
he said that wouldn't be my first choice
he attacked the woman reporter writing
the story called her disgusting as he
has called a number of women during this
campaign
Donald thinks belittling women makes him
bigger he goes after their dignity their
self-worth and I don't think there is a
woman anywhere who doesn't know what
that feels like
so we not believe what Donald thinks and
what he says and how he acts toward
women that's who
Donald is I think it's really up to all
of us to demonstrate who we are so this
is roughly what I suggested saying we
can demonstrate who we are sort of an
illusion to voters can decide whether
this is something they want to vote for
I think it was a good move by Hillary
Clinton to sort of say women know what
it feels like to have their self-worth
entangled with their physical appearance
and clearly Donald Trump is someone who
is who is doing exactly that in his
ranking of women in his writing off some
of the sexual assault allegations by
implying either two different degrees of
directness that he would or wouldn't be
with a woman that that has the physical
appearance of some of the accusers and
then the whole thing wrapped up with a
line that brought the crowd to laughter
because of how absurd it is Donald
Trump's infamous line about respecting
women now and in the future and
particularly for our children and our
grandchildren mr. Trump nobody has more
respect for women than I do nobody
nobody has more ways everybody and
frankly those sewers have been largely
debunked yeah the stories have not been
too Bonnington the audience could not
keep it together
how can you even repeat at this point
that you are the most respectful person
to women it's just absolutely laughable
and laughter is exactly what it
triggered in that debate Hall Warby
Parker is offering a free five day home
Tryon to give you the opportunity to
check out their glasses I personally
wear Warby Parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trialed dot-com slash TDP s I don't
really like going into glasses stores
and trying on glasses while the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home Tryon I was
able to pick five pairs that I liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I like the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big
corporations that keep prices very high
like $300 for prescription glasses high
which is just insane Warby Parker
glasses start at $95 that's what mine
cost and for every pair of glasses sold
Warby Parker distributes a pair of
glasses to someone in need
you can try five pairs and see what you
like check out the at home trial and
support our show by going to Warby
Parker comm slash TDP s it costs nothing